President Trump says the US economy is
strong and we're not headed toward a
recession but his administration is
looking for ways to boost the economy
Ben Tracy is at the White House Ben what
are they considering well good morning
we're told that they are considering new
tax cuts but White House officials are
also throwing cold water on a report in
The Washington Post of a payroll tax cut
telling us that is not something they're
considering right now
now payroll taxes are the amount of
money taken out of people's paychecks to
fund Social Security and Medicare if
that tax is lowered it's seen as a way
to quickly increase consumer spending
and juice the economy so why is the
White House concerned about the economy
well a majority of economists predict
the u.s. is headed for a recession by
2021 at the latest so tax cuts now could
be a way to delay a recession until
after the 2020 election on Twitter
President Trump continues to tout what
he is calling a strong economy but at
the same time he's also criticizing
Federal Reserve Chairman Jerome Powell
for what the president calls a
horrendous lack of vision for not
cutting interest rates enough mr. Trump
called for the Federal Reserve to slash
rates by a full percentage point that's
an amount the Fed would normally only
consider during a recession now the
president is well aware that his
approval rating is strongly tied to his
handling of the economy about half of
all Americans say they approve of the
way the president is handling the
economy and that is a big issue for him
heading into the 2020 election Gale got
it Thank You Ben